Ich hoffe das stream geht wieder
Geht das stream wieder?
Also ich kann
Ich kanns bei mir selbst nicht anmachen
Geht wie? Okay nice
Gut ich start das Spiel wieder
Also ich glaube
Der PC ist seit ich ihn habe
Zweimal gecrasht
Zweimal
Ich wusste gar nicht dass dieser PC crashen kann
Ehrlich gesagt
So ich starte mal wieder
Und ich bin jetzt extra silent
Weil das Game wieder die Lautstärke auf 100%
Dreht gleich
Nerv nicht rum
Nein
Super ich bin silent
Silent bin ich silent
Ich muss jetzt die Lautstärke wieder umstellen
ESMR Stream LUL
Ah geh weg
Recording
So
Jetzt gehts wieder
Der ganze PC ist gecrasht
Komplett blue screen
Ich hab hier den Nvidia Treiber
So ein bisschen in Verdacht
Dass sie da Dinge machen die noch nicht so gut funktionieren
Wie gesagt der PC ist seit ich ihn
Ende 2013 gekauft habe
Der ist zweimal gecrasht oder so
Wow Team deathmatch
Ich hab dazu übrigens gleich umgestellt auf 720p
Mit 60 FPS
Für mehr Konsolen Experience
Oh Gibraltar
Gibraltar? Ist das die Overwatch Map?
Bloß vor 100 Jahren
Watchpoint Gibraltar
Also da oben rechts
Ist Winston irgendwo drinnen
Beziehungsweise Winstons Opa
Enter
Das da will ich haben
Jawoll passion
Auf gehts
Wenn der PC jetzt nochmal abkackt liegt es definitiv am game
Püppisch
Haut rein
Wir machen jetzt hier
Wir machen jetzt Camper Modus
Aber nicht
Die Waffe verzieht
Muss weg
Was?
Dass menschliche auch kein maximal 30 FPS wahrnehmen
Ja ich weiß, ich weiß
Ich weiß auch nicht warum ich auf 60 FPS spiele
Ich weiß
Und wenn du ein Auge zu machst kannst du dann bloß noch 15 wahrnehmen
Ist halt so
Die Waffe macht zu wenig Damage auf Range
Sack
Sack Balls Alter
Da ist bestimmt hier einer rechts
Flankerino
Ups
Da ist einer
Granate
Flanken, flanken, flanken
Direkt
Moment warum hab ich nur 60 FPS
Warum hab ich nur 60 FPS
Siehst du hier wie immer
Kluges, kluges Movement
Triple, triple
Quad
Es war Quad, ich hab es genau gesehen
Quad kill
Es waren nicht nur zwei, es waren vier
Da ist der nächste
Geschneibt
Alter, geschneit 7-2
Erster richtig
Warum hab ich so wenig FPS
Ich hab mit 1080
TI
Es ruckelt, es ruckelt
Ich glaub's nicht
Das Game ruckelt
Ich, ich, ich
Ich erwartet
Oh fuck da will ich nicht runter
Ich erwarte dass ein Game nicht ruckelt mit der teuersten Grafikkarte
die es zur Zeit gibt
Moment
Passt zum
Hat er jetzt noch gelebt oder nicht
Komm her
Ich wusste dass du hinterher kommst
Quad
Triple
Ja okay fast
Ja die Titan ist teurer
Titan 10
Titan ist total bescheuert sich zu kaufen
1080DE hat sogar Sinn sich zu kaufen
Aber Titan ist einfach nur
Unnötig teuer
Der kommt hier lang jetzt
Der wird jetzt jebaited wieder jetzt
Jebaited
Eckencamper
Der will flanken
Lol
Flank dead
Oh wir haben
Wir haben eine UAV
Auf die Range
Ist glaub ich meine Waffe nicht so gut
Guck mal wir haben UAV
UAV nice
Oh
Oh ich hab kaum noch
Doch ich hab noch Munition
Komm runter
Was drückt zweimal um den Suppressor zu
Ertaschen was soll ich zweimal drücken
Ah zweimal
Suppressor
Nice
Aber da macht es noch weniger
Damage über Range
Aber die können wir bashen jetzt hier
Richtig krass bashen können die
Ich flank jetzt mal da hinten rum
Ich will wissen wo es da lang geht
Ich einfach die
Hälfte der Viewer verloren hab
Wegen geilem Stream Crash
Wo ist hier was
Krasser Schneiber
Den gucken wir uns jetzt mal an
Wat
Wie
One hit
In Bauch
Oh oh oh ich ahne Schlimmes
Ich ahne Schlimmes
Das wird Trickshot
Game 2
Geregt
Ok der Typ sackt
Den messern wir jetzt
Bam
Ich gucke jetzt nochmal ob
Das Ding meine Settings behalten hat
Graphics
Ja das hat
Passt alles
Das ist alles richtig
Komm wir sind erster
Vor allem wir
Moment
Scheiß Sniper da
Ah du darfst nicht
Daniel lohnen du darfst nicht vergessen ich hab auch keine
Soll nicht gute CPU aber trotzdem
Das Game sollte mit mehr laufen
Im Team Deathmatch als mit
Mit der 1080ti als mit 100
Mit 75 FPS
Also die Waffe ist
Die Waffe gefällt mir jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig zumindest auf der Map
Weil
Die halt auf Range ziemlich sackt
Ne
Ich muss weg
Oh hinten
Ok der weiß nicht dass ich da bin
Ja
Schön die Kill geklaut
Ich weiß nicht wo ich hier lang
Soll mit der Waffe
Weil das ist eher so eine Midrange Map
Und vor allem meine Waffe mit Schalldämpfer drauf ist
Nicht schlecht auf Range
Ich muss mal hören
Oh wo gehts hier lang
Kann man hier schön
Kann man hier rumflenken
Schneiber
Der hat es nicht besser verdient
Jetzt Spawnen sie hinter uns
Das ist Call of Duty die Spawnen jetzt hinter uns
Ne unsere Leute Spawnen noch hinten
Man darf nie den Call of Duty Spawnen unterschätzen
Fuck
Bombe
Ja wir geten zu Cover
Wir sind in Cover gegettet
Oh die Waffe sackt
Ich muss die Waffe wechseln
Das Ding ist auf Midrange einfach mies
Und wir sind in Cover
Wir sind in Cover
Der Ding ist auf Midrange einfach mies
Und eins muss ich sagen
Den Recoil haben sie relativ
Also mehr anspruchsvoll
Kann man nicht sagen
Aber das ist zumindest nicht so
Extrem simpel zu kontrollieren
Zumindest mit der Waffe
Also komplett Dauerfeuer und alles wegholzen
Ist nicht
Zumindest mit der
Und halt auf die Range
Denkst du kannst mich ausstrafen
Oder was
Muss noch mal zehn Jahre üben
Den habe ich also sound gefällt mir sound hört man wirklich
Pass auf pass auf pass auf pass auf
Okay die waffe ist auf range
Aber erster kann ich mitnehmen
Lauter switch während runde geht wahrscheinlich nicht aber wir machen mal die schalldämpfe ab
Ich glaube das ist all das ist mehr nervig als dass es was bringt
Da für mich aus der fahre umkratten gegner
Hauptsache erster da bin ich bin ich zufrieden mit speichern wir uns doch mal das Gameplaymaterial haben
Markspiel wieder kort erfüllt im jahr 2011 zurückversatz mal gucken
Sollte ich mal sagen dieses visier was der da hatte sah ehrlich gesagt nicht sonderlich world war two mäßig aus
Aber es liegt aber das liegt einfach an meinem namen dass ich jetzt so gute stats habe
Muss es
Aller wie mich das ärgern dass das stream abgekackt ist
Das ist einfach nur die hälfte der leute da sind von den die eben da waren sagt einfach nur
Aber ich habe wieder mein load auch nicht geändert noch mal püppel spielen
Meine vorschau stimmt übrigens auch nicht muss man wie freshen hier
Kann man das noch schälen schälen was moment leute 63 fps
Ich kann ich meint ich kann mich nicht bewegen das game spack
Na das ist ja ein klassisches spiel das ist ja toll das ist jetzt schon der dritte crash in der stunde
Ich ahne ja schlimmes also wenn das ne beta ist die werbung für das game machen soll mit dem punkto stabilität macht die definitiv keine
Das ist ja toll das ist jetzt schon der dritte crash in der stunde
Ich ahne ja schlimmes also wenn das ne beta ist die werbung für das game machen soll mit dem punkto
Stabilität macht die definitiv keine werbung für das game
Ja was auf gleich kraschwürde pz. Oh fuck
Ja so jetzt wieder besser auf game überspringen
So ich gucke noch mal schnell ob das hier alles noch stimmt
Ja mehr kann ich dann einstellen
Mehr geht nicht mehr kann ich dann einstellen
Und ich glaube nicht dass das game probleme hat mit mit mit anti lasing settings oder sowas in der richtung das macht meine grafikkarte mit links
Ja ja das können wir machen ich gehe schon mal in discord wir spielen jetzt hier mal ordentlich team team based
Hello guys ich gehe schon mal in discord kannst du auch reinkommen wenn du willst
So discord oh ich muss discord
Wo stellt man überhaupt die pay to win tast also bin ich kaputt im kopf manchmal die push to talk kaste ein
Push push to talk wo ist push to talk push to talk
Es gibt ja auch kein slider oder so das ist einfach mal besonders gut zu bedienen mit dem pc
Z ist eine gute tast da komme ich eh nicht drauf aus versehen
So dann stelle ich jetzt noch mal in discord push to talk ein und dann passt das game dürfte übrigens mal losgehen
Discord push to talk wo ging das nochmal sprache video sprache bla push push to talk
Push to talk mit ja so
Ok test test
Test das heißt ja passt also ja wenn du willst kannst du ins discord
Achst du soll im discord schreiben
Ok auf gehts nächste runde die map hatten wir schon mal ganz am Anfang
Oh wir spielen gegen den gefürchteten qg plan mit 62 fps seht ihr das flugzeug ruckeln
Ok jetzt jetzt moment moment da habe ich 158 fps und da habe ich 69
Das sieht nach ziemlich schlechter optimierung aus
Ich dachte wir campen die jetzt einfach mal kaputt
Aber nope keine chancen
Ok die sind links die sind links
Den holen wir uns auf der linken seite der ist hier noch der muss hier noch sein
Der flenkt von hinten rum gerade ich weiß aber nicht wo er lang ist außen rum
Alter was ist mit dem game los was zum teufel ist mit dem game los habt ihr das grad gesehen
Oh beste verbindung beste verbindung
Ich mein das ist doch der witz wie soll ich mit der verbindung spielen
Ist das game zufällig wieder p2p kann das sein ist das nicht serverbasiert
Also wenn das nicht serverbasiert ist dann kann das game noch so gut sein noch so viel
Spaß machen ich werde es definitiv
Ich bin gerade auf einem super guten server mit einem balken
Mit einem balken ja läuft richtig gut
Was ist ein balken ein ping
Ein balken ist für call of duty das was für die pc master race ein ping ist
Also so ein beacon wie beim sonar oder?
Genau
Ich muss jetzt mal kurz gucken wie deine lautstärke ist
Lautstärke sag mal bitte was
Sonartest
Ja Leute sag mal passt die lautstärke voll ja kriegst du das ok
Ich frage gerade mal die leute ob die lautstärke so passt oder ob ich noch was rum stellen
muss
Ja ich gehe jetzt raus ich habe quasi 300er ping oder sowas gerade
Oh man ey läuft ja schon mal gut ne
300er ping muss echt nicht sein
Also 300er ping muss nicht sein
Übrigens game ist schon 3 oder 4 mal gecrashed
Echt
Ja
Wie macht man das jetzt mit leute einladen und so
Hast du da ein plan
Sozial vielleicht
Social Freunde
Villa einladen
Ah da bist du ja
Ich hab dich eingeladen
Ah ne du hast mich auch eingeladen
Jetzt haben wir uns gegenseitig eingeladen
Ja da komme ich zu dir
Ok nice
Funktionieren
Ich muss falls ich mal nicht antworte dann vergesse ich push to talk zu drücken
Ja wobei ich glaube das brauchst du gerade echt nicht
Was meinste
Talk oder so
Push to talk
Ne ich laber halt mit bestreben ne
So
So geh los wäschen
Aber dass die immer noch auf peer to peer setzen das verstehe ich
Ich vermute mal dass das peer to peer so scheiße wie das gerade gelaufen ist
Ich werde egal wie geil das game ist ich werde das nicht spielen wenn es peer to peer ist
Aber gute Verbindung
Rekt alter hardcore wrecked
Outgestrafed
Was soll ich sonst was willst du
Achso ich hab keine Ahnung irgendwas
Einfach mal reinballern
Ja machen wir mal desmatch ne runde
Typisch der call of duty tot oder schön von hinten
Die leute sagen du klingst in meinem stream scheiße und in deinem viel besser
Das kann schon sein das ist halt discord
Gab es in zweit den wavekrieg schon blindgranaten
Keine ahnung aber wenn es das call of duty gibt muss es das gegeben haben
Das ist ja immer sehr akkurat
Schneibt
Tyrannosaurus wrecked ja
Die sniper gehen wir übrigens jetzt schon auf den sack
Alter die voice lines sind ja mega verpackt
Lauts wie die ohren raus
Wie viele
Ich habe nicht aufgespießt
Alles klar
Von hinten wieder
Der chat klärt uns gerade auf dass es quickscope natürlich auch schon gab
Also unsere kritik ist unberechtigt
Die sprüche der deutschen wie in echt
Scheiße er ist tot
Aber eine sache fährt mir jetzt schon auf was richtig widerlich ist
Scheint keine movement
Meinst du bist instant auf 100%
Die leute auf links links links
Die wisslauf von hinten geohnt
So
Jetzt werden wir sie mal outplayen
Es wird richtig outplayed
Sagt euch leute
Outplayed ist oder sind
Oder auch nicht ich brauche eine andere waffe das ding gefällt mir nicht
Stargate ja
Spawn trapping näher
Sieht bis jetzt nicht so aus aber wahrscheinlich müssen die leute und die richtigen die richtigen spots finden
Wo gesporn trap wird
Direkt
Also zielen muss man nach wie vor nicht in dem gelb
Achtung Achtung
Scheiße
Was da oben
Fliegt ein flugzeug
Das geht ab
Die fritzbombe
Nicht fritz facks die fritzbombe
Ich kann mit der waffe nicht anstinken gegen den gegner auf die range
Achtung wir gehen jetzt rein
Da kann man bestimmt oben hier lang
Von hinten
Jetzt kommt gleich von hinten was
Wo sind sie hin
Einfach mal afk
Ein bisschen schneller hier
Wir gucken uns gleich noch mal perks und so zeugs an
Ich versuche halt dass die mir uns nicht
Die map sieht ekelhaft aus ich finde die map spielt sich ganz gut
Die fritzbombe wird getroppt
Ich wollte gerade sagen es war gegner drin
Die kommen jetzt hier die werden gebäscht
Nachladen
Ich brauche eine andere waffe
Macht überhaupt kein damage
Achtung jetzt werden sie gehauen
Jetzt werden sie richtig gehauen
Bald hier was lang kommen werden sie gebäscht
Kommt nichts lang
So blöd dass das stream fort abgekackt ist
Kommt her
Kann man hier raus
Gehen wir hier oben raus
Ich glaube die sind in den bunker drin
Voll aufs dach vom bunker
Ich habe echt so ein
Ich habe irgendwie so ein gegner ausweich modus ungewollt
Ich laufe mal an den vorbei
Ich sehe du hast sie gehauen
Du hast sie gehauen
Was hast du für eine waffe
Das ist Sturmgewehr
Ich habe jetzt diese psh freigeschaltet
Das ding macht überhaupt kein damage
Diese kleinen MPs da oder was das sein sollen die taugen gar nichts
Ich probiere jetzt auch noch was anderes aus
Ja also die beta ist schon offen
Wie findest du das game
Kann ich bis jetzt noch nicht sagen zu es ist ziemlich unstabil
Bist du rausgegangen
Moment du man kann die erst mit rank 14 anlocken steht da die stg 44
Echt
Oder vielleicht welche division bist du vielleicht haben die divisions unterschiedliche
Luft land aber da habe ich auch
Bei mir steht stg 44 kannst du kannst du anlocken erst mit mit 14
Auch immer
Gucken in game fühlt sich bei dir das game dass das eben schwammig anfragen am chat ich kann das schlecht beurteilen ich finde es geht
Das einzige ist du kannst ja wieder aus der hüfte sprayen ohne ende
Wie findest du das
Also ich finde es direkt
Ja ich habe jetzt auch nichts gemerkt dass es super schwammig wäre oder so
Ah die standardklasse hat die stg okay ja dann nehme ich mal die standardklasse
Es gibt bloß einen team
Nee
Es gibt gibraltar gibt es noch
Und es könnte sein dass noch was anderes gespielt also die und gibraltar gibt es auf jeden fall
14 14 gigabyte
Flanken jetzt gleich mal hier
Die standardklasse macht schon mal guten eindruck
Wo sind die gegner
Suche gegner
Die sind alle im campen im haus
Jetzt alles dauernd
Das ist immer was besser spielst du die team deathmatch wenn du keine gegner siehst weißt du
Hinter dir
Ich finde keine gegner
Es gibt ja zwei
Oh y bayonett charge
Ach ist auch nele
Ja endlich mal
Kuh ist gut
Ich fand v immer beschissen
Da bewegt sich was
Oh hier der jump shot
Da hat es einen scuff am start
Ja der tip der spammt die ganze zeit den jump knopf
Ich wusste dass er jetzt raus kommt
Also ich finde das nicht schwamm ich muss sagen
Hier ist gute flank weg
Da ist er schon
Ich denke da kann er mich auen
Die kommen jetzt von der seite gleich den fangen wir ab
Jump shoten da wollen sie wieder jump shoten
Die flanken wir jetzt
Den verarschen wir jetzt
Achtung
Der wird geregt
Was war das denn gerade
Ah shotgun oh ne ich weiß jetzt schon über was geflammt wird
Ich war jetzt schon was geflammt wird in dem game
Oh ne leute was meint ihr
Du hast manchmal auch hitmarker obwohl du schon den gegner längst gekillt hast
Der ploppt dann einfach so aus
So hast du ihn getroffen dabei geht das gar nicht
Ist noch einer drin
Moment Hä
War das der gleiche gegner
Komm her
Ich hasse diese leute wie in call of duty im king deathmatch am ap
Die was denn
Am abcampen
Muss sein
Also denken die sich wahrscheinlich
Weißt du da hast du ein spiel wo du innerhalb von einer
Und dann campst du
Also du hast ja quasi instant respawn
Also krass oder
Wie schnell das geht
Wenn er halt wirklich so schlecht in einem spiel ist
Ja aber das war ja immer so
Rumgecamp in team deathmatch
Mit der habe ich mir runtergefallen
Ja ich habe gerade eine um die wand erschossen
Fuck
Nice rekt
Pro taktik rechnen sie natürlich
Was hältst du von fortnite
Also ich habe weder groß als pupke gespielt noch fortnite
Also fortnite habe ich gar nicht gespielt
Pupke habe ich ein bisschen gespielt
Ich halte dieses battle royale zeug
Wo ist der gegner hin
Wo ist
Habt ihr das gesehen leute
Als ernsthaft kann mir einer erklären wo der gegner hin ist
Der ist einfach despawned
Habt ihr das gesehen
Der war auf einmal weg
Krasser shit
Kann man hier raus
Hier kann man raus
Jetzt kommt gleich einer von hinten
Das ist call of duty da kommen immer leute von hinten
Können nicht von hinten kommen
Aber wir jumpen jetzt einfach mal um
Rekt
Glaubt doch die ganze zeit dieses paketverlust zeichnen
Oder was das sein soll
Ja ja stimmt rechts oben
Jetzt habe ich ja geguckt
Ach nee das ist nur der killcam
Ich dachte die punkte oben rechts oder so
Das sind so 3 quadrate
Der ist gestorben ich habe einen assist bekommen okay
Das habe ich so nicht gecheckt
Übrigens fairer spawn
Warum jumpshotten die alle wie die pros
Oder wie die möchte gern pros
Möchte gern pros eigentlich eher
Das sieht fast schon bescheuert aus
Die denken wahrscheinlich sie spielen black ops
Fuck fuck fuck
Rekt
Hardcore Rekt
Also die sdg 4 in 40 gefällt mir gut
Die sdg 4 in 40 gefällt mir gut
Übrigens eben gerade stream gehabt beim starten
170 zuschauer pc gecrasht
Ja jetzt nur noch 100
Also nicht das ich da nicht in den spot pumpen lasse
Nicht das ich das schlecht finden würde oder so
Also Leute ich finde es gut das ihr alle da seid
Aber sind schon echt in sehr ungünstig im moment gecrasht
Moment
Ja man denkt immer
Schleekorner denkt immer nach der ersten runde ist gar nicht schlecht
Und dann gehts einem auf den sack
Also die filmbinder geschwindigkeit im spiel haben sie es echt übertrieben
Der typ macht werbung für seine seite kann das sein
Ja das sind halt diese komischen gameplay seiten
Hast du auch wie viel fps hast du
Ich habe 66 gerade 105
Hier scheint doch ein bisschen cpu bauen zu sein
Also ich krieg hier nur 44 nicht voll wenn ich in stream laufen muss aber
Ohne müsste das eigentlich schon hinhauen glaube ich
Das kann doch nicht sein dass wir quasi 60 fps unterschicken
Ne jetzt habe ich wieder 100 kommt auf die map an wo auf der map man ist
Ja mehr gegner auf einmal bitte
Danach probieren wir mal anderen modus aus
Aber ich muss sagen das handling von den waffen finde ich ganz gut bis jetzt
Das gefällt mir ganz gut
Der wird sich frei natürlich
Hier kann man auch vorbei
Das habe ich auch schon geschafft
Das habe ich auch gepackt
Beide haben es geklappt
Egal wir haben es geklappt
Voll verkackt
Ja Leute wie ist euer Eindruck so vor den ersten paar runden zu gucken
So was passiert wenn man fett wengert
Das kann man bestimmt umbelegen
Wobei ich bin mir da gar nicht so sicher wenn ich die anderen settings angucke wie sie für den pc angepasst sind
Ich würde übrigens gerne rausgehen aber es geht nicht gerade
Ich mache nur lobby
Also ich habe beides verlassen
Also ich muss sagen das macht Bock
Kann man sich nicht so drauf verlassen dass es in der ersten runde Bock macht
Ist war nicht dieser neue mission modus den probieren wir jetzt mal aus
Sieben Games
Also ich muss sagen auf offener fläche habe ich schon ziemliche einbrüche
Es kann nicht sein dass ich mit einer 1080 ti 60 fps habe
Ich weiß nicht was die da machen
Aber das mache ich mit der ich mache über grafikkarten encoder
Also das sollte eigentlich nicht wirklich viel ziehen
So jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt kommt es darauf an
Was sind deine aktuellen einstellungen alles post processing aus andre
Post processing aus rest standard was war vorfurcht gesteuert
Ich habe eine bombe hingelegt warum habe ich die bombe hingelegt
Warum habe ich die bombe hingelegt
Ich würde gerne mal ein bayonet
Irgendwie
Ich
Ich bin überhaupt nicht gewöhn push und pop zu drücken
Du kannst das ausmachen also bei mir ist gerade eh nichts los
Ja
Was
Ich stelle mir das richtig schwierig vor das haus hier anzunehmen
Da habe ich schon ein flamepost gesehen auf reddit
Wir pushen da jetzt mal
Wir machen jetzt mal was mit spawn campen
Die gegner können zu wenig
Sprachaktivierung
Ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen
Ich kann mich nicht mehr bewegen ich habe input lag von von zwei sekunden